a software company like google maintains
a lot of code like seriously a lot like
over 2 billion lines of code and nearly
100 terabytes of data to go along with
it it's a scale that's hard to even
comprehend like all the stars in the
universe or all the universes in the
multiverse and you have thousands of
engineers around the world working on it
simultaneously but get this they store
all their code in a single monolithic
repository and they've been doing it
since the very beginning today google's
monorepo is likely the largest code base
in the world but it takes an
extraordinary effort to scale they have
their own homegrown version control
system and a highly advanced build tool
called bazel which goes by the much
cooler name of blaze internally in
today's video you'll learn everything
you ever wanted to know about mono repos
and how you the humble javascript
developer can build a high performance
mono repo in your garage if you're new
here like and subscribe we're so close
to 1 million and if you hit the button
right now we might even make it there by
christmas you may have heard some
exciting news last week that vercell
acquired a company called turbo repo
it's a build tool written in go that
makes it really easy to manage multiple
apps and packages in a single git
repository but first let's answer the
question of why would i want to use a
mono repo there are many reasons but at
the highest level it gives you
visibility of your company's entire code
base without the need to track down and
clone a bunch of different repos in
addition it provides consistency because
you can share things like your eslint
config a ui library of web components
for your design system utility libraries
documentation and so on the real power
though comes in the form of dependency
management imagine somebody makes a
breaking change to a shared library all
affected applications will know
instantly and monorepo tools can
actually help you visualize the entire
dependency graph of your software when
it comes to third party dependencies a
mono repo can dedupe packages that are
used in multiple apps a mono repo is
also ideal for continuous integration
and automation because your code is
already unified by default making it
much easier to build and test everything
together but there is one big problem
with monorepos and that's the fact that
they're big as the monorepo becomes
larger there are more things to test
more things to build and a lot more
artifacts to store as a result vs code
will lag trying to process the massive
git history and you'll need a 20 minute
smoke break waiting for everything to
run on the ci server after every commit
to operate a mono repo at scale it's
absolutely essential to have the right
tooling that's why facebook created buck
microsoft created rush and google
created bazel you just need a phd in
order to use it luckily there are other
options out there the most basic
approach is to use your package manager
like yarn or npm to define workspaces
these tools basically configure your
project with a root level package json
which then has nested workspaces like
apps and packages that are linked back
to the root level project a cool thing
about this is that it will dedupe your
node modules which means if you have the
same package installed in multiple apps
it will only be installed once it also
allows you to orchestrate scripts like
if you want to build or test all of your
apps at the same time that's a good easy
place to start but if you're building an
open source project that publishes a
bunch of different packages then you'll
likely want to look into a tool called
learn which is a tool that can optimize
the workflow of a multi-package repo
here's an example turf js is a
geospatial library that has a ton of
different packages that are essentially
helper functions or working with
geolocation data each one of them can be
installed as its own package and lives
in its own subdirectory here on the repo
lerna is the tool that it uses to help
manage this workflow efficiently most
importantly it allows you to publish all
of your packages to npm with a single
command these tools are great at
configuring monorepos but they still
suffer from the same problem i mentioned
earlier they become really slow and
difficult to work with as they grow
larger one problem is the installation
of dependencies if you're looking to
improve your install speed and easy
optimization to make is to replace npm
with pnpm it's a drop-in replacement
that will install your dependencies
globally and sim link them and that can
make your install speeds up to three
times faster that's a nice upgrade but
what really makes a monorepo slow is the
constant need to recompile rebuild and
retest everything and that brings us to
the fun part of the video where we talk
about an entirely different class of
tools that can make your mono rebo
operate at the speed of google the tools
i'll be comparing are nx and turbo repo
they both operate as what i would
describe as a smart build system what i
mean by that is they create a dependency
tree between all of your apps and
packages which allows the tooling to
understand what needs to be tested and
what needs to be rebuilt whenever
there's a change to the code base they
cache any files or artifacts that have
already been built and can also run jobs
in parallel to execute everything much
faster we'll look at some example code
in just a second but first what is the
difference between nx and turbo repo nx
has been around for about five years and
was created by two x googlers turbo repo
on the other hand was just open source
the other day it was created by jared
palmer who you might know from the react
ecosystem with packages like formic at
this point turbo repo is a lot more
minimal than nx nx can do everything
that turbo repo does and has a lot of
features beyond it like a cli that can
automatically generate boilerplate code
for you a plug-in ecosystem a vs code
extension and something called
distributed task execution which allows
you to distribute work across multiple
continuous integration servers it's a
pretty amazing feature from a technical
standpoint and was inspired by bazel on
one hand it's great to have all these
features but on the other hand it might
be a little more than you actually need
nx has been criticized for requiring too
much configuration although i don't
necessarily agree with that if you're
only using the core nx features that
configuration is actually very minimal
that being said turbo repo feels like a
tool that goes out of its way to get out
of your way for example if you're
already using yarn or npm workspaces all
you have to do is add a few lines of
configuration to your package json and
you now have a magically super fast mono
repo when it comes to dependencies both
tools visualize the dependency graph
although nx does a much better job of
this but again it's had a lot more time
to bake in the oven another cool thing
that both of them do is remote caching
with turbo repo when it caches something
it can also cache those files on for
cell that means if bob builds the
application then alice checks it out on
a different computer the entire cache
can be downloaded remotely instead of
wastefully rebuilding and recomputing
everything in the mono repo and that can
save a huge amount of time for a large
organization the final comparison point
i want to make is that turbo repo is
written in go while nx is written in
typescript in theory this could result
in faster startup times when running
turbo repo but the underlying language
is not where the performance gains come
from it depends on when the computations
take place and how they're cached but
i'd be interested to see some benchmarks
between these two tools now it's time
for you to build your first monorepo i
already have a video on nx if you want
to check that out but today we're going
to take a first look at turbo repo you
can add it to an existing monorepo or
they also have a template to start from
scratch run npx create turbo from the
command line and that should bring up a
menu with some gradient text that says
turbo repo it'll give you the option for
a package manager and i'll go with yarn
as the default when we open up the
project in vs code you'll see that we
have two root level directories for apps
and packages where apps are the actual
applications you deploy like a next.js
or react app for example and packages
are the different configurations
utilities and ui libraries that those
apps depend on now if we open up the
root level package json you'll notice we
have workspaces set up for apps and
packages there as well then towards the
bottom you'll notice the turbo
configuration this is where you
configure a pipeline to run tasks
efficiently normally in a mono repo
everything runs one by one you do all
your linting first then you do all your
builds then your testing and finally
your deployments with a pipeline you can
explicitly tell turbo what a task
depends on like you can run lint
whenever but to run your build you'll
want to make sure that all the
dependencies have been built first the
carrot symbol refers to dependencies
then to test the application we'll want
to make sure that the build has
completed and to deploy will ensure that
build test and lint have all been
completed a pipeline like this allows
you to condense the timeline and utilize
more cpu resources to deliver faster
builds and that's pretty much all it
takes to get started we can now build or
develop all of our apps in parallel if
we run yarn run dev it serves both of
the next js applications in this repo at
the same time in the terminal you can
see where it's using the cache in the
browser you get two apps running at the
same time without having to deal with
multiple processes an interesting thing
to notice here is that if we go into the
package json and one of the applications
you'll notice that it has dependencies
like ui that are linked to a star
character and the same for config and ts
config these are dependencies that live
in the monorepo under the packages
directory what's cool about this is that
if we go into our ui package and make a
change the change will be reflected
instantly in both applications at the
same time there's no need to recompile
and reinstall a dependency everything is
continuously integrated into the entire
code base and the awesome thing about
turbo is that everything becomes much
faster by default like if we run the
build command the first time around
might take a couple minutes but when we
run it a second time everything will be
cached and that run might only take a
few hundred milliseconds at least in
theory there's a bug on windows right
now that's ruining my video but normally
this build would be done in a matter of
milliseconds i blame myself for not
using linux to summarize mono repos can
be an awesome tool when you have a large
complex project the great thing about
tools like turbo and nx is that they
dramatically lower the barrier of entry
to scale a massive code base a mono repo
might be overkill for your blog but if
you're the technical co-founder of a
company it's definitely an approach to
building software that you want to be
aware of i'm going to go ahead and wrap
things up there if you want access to
more advanced javascript development
content consider becoming a pro member
at fireship io thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one